the Cooper's confrontation a blossom
bombshell and lodge lies revealed all
that family drama and so much more in
Sweetwater secrets oh my goodness river
babes we have so much to discuss as
always I'm your host Liana Galera and
this is your Sweetwater secrets
after-show for episode 216 chapter 29
primary colors now there were a lot of
things that I loved about this episode
and plenty of moments that made me want
to scream so get ready for a vicious
round of hisses and kisses consider
yourself warned
plus I've got a new segment today called
catfight as two of your favorite
Riverdale ladies face off but first
let's quickly relive the top headlines
of the week in the blue and gold
breakdown first up Alice Cooper is
confronted with the truth about chick
and she doesn't care
in fact she's known all along just like
we have that hell is not chicks father
you are not the father
now after scaring the crap at a chick
with a Zippo lighter
Betty's half-brother turned the tables
on her and threatened to go to the cops
and frame her for murder
chick also whined a lot so Betty did
with any girl with the psychotic brother
and brainwashed mother would do she
moved in with her boyfriend you have to
let me stay here over in the Andrew's
household
Archie's mom returned and helped Fred in
his quest to break free from the lodges
contractual clutches she also announced
that she's sticking around for a while
while Fred chases after his dreams I'm
gonna run from there and in the
super-creepy blossom household penelope
teamed up with Cheryl's uncle Claudius
and nearly killed Nana Rose but their
diabolical plan continued after making
it seem like Cheryl was paranoid which
she was not Penelope banished our
beloved bombshell to what looked like
the sisters of quiet mercy and forced
her to undergo conversion therapy she's
going to rid you of all those naughty
demons
oh you guys this episode had a lot of
frustrating moments including the fact
that there was barely any romance in it
which leads us into
this week seven seconds in heaven okay
two words river babes
Shoni sleepover okay sure there are
other members of the Vixens at thistle
house as well but there was only one
girl that Cheryl really wanted in her
bed although we didn't get our first
show nice mooch I'm kind of loving the
slow burn between these two beauties but
if I don't get a kiss in the next two
episodes I'm gonna lose it this is not
the time for drama and flying off the
handle meanwhile things in barchi land
we're pretty non-existent on the romance
front but bug-head treat advanced a few
acute compliments and kisses as they
went from longtime couple to brand-new
roomies good point
but now let's get ready to rumble
because it's time for a brand new
segment called tight all right guys
in one corner we had Veronica Lodge
daddy's girl girlfriend Archie Andrews
and lover of pearls and presents in the
other corner we had josie mccoy legit
diva former lead singer of the Pussycats
and queen of sass and ever-changing
hairdos so what went down between these
two frenemies this week or even on
speaking terms Veronica and round one
Veronica I've got a taste of Ethel's
mayhem with a strawberry milkshake to
the face in front of everyone Vee took
her anger out on Reggie but apparently
in a rage was misdirected in round two
Veronica bribed a reluctant Josie to be
her celebrity endorsement with the
promise of The Andy Cohen spotlight so
the two woman shared the stage for a
political duet what's going on
but the claws really came out in round
three when Ethel passed out flyers
reviewing the truths that Veronica knew
about her parents plans to turn
Riverdale into a prison town all along
now because of these lies and bribes V
lust be as a running mate and possibly
as the best friend
who is the winner of this first catfight
say congratulations to our leopard print
a champion josie natori sorry not sorry
river babes but I'm with Josie on this
one
now Veronica's been pretty Shady this
season especially when she stole the
Pussycats from Josie how do you agree
with me it's totally okay if you don't
we're all friends here so hit the
comments right now and tell me your
thoughts on this catfight whoo girls we
had to stick together
but now it's time for my Riverdale rants
and raves in this week's kisses and
kisses the biggest hits of the night is
going straight to Penelope blossom for
locking up her daughter in that
disgusting place and throwing away the
key now just a quick reminder to
everyone you are free to love whomever
you want and don't ever let anyone tell
you otherwise or try to change you
love is love back - hisses hisses - Andy
Cohen's random cameo now don't get me
wrong I love the housewives and I tune
in to watch what happens live every
night but this guest appearance was
really bizarre and out of place and
sorry Andy you're not that good of an
actor
I'm here to endorse my great friend
Hermione Lodge this is to the harm that
came to Nana Rose and I'm not just
saying that because it also interrupted
our first potential show knee kiss but
also I kind of totally am and I never
thought this would happen but you guys
this hiss is going straight to Kevin for
selling buddy out to chick but an even
bigger hiss is going to check for crying
mommy and being a little hisses - Alice
Cooper for calling chick damaged instead
of seeing that her son is a full-fledged
psychopath and hisses - Alice for
denying the FPS chicks father even
though it's so damn obvious you are the
and I hate to say it that hisses -
Jughead eat a burger dude because this
hole reopened Southside High Crusade is
making a pretty damn hangry and I
understand that you want to preserve the
spirit of the serpents but I've got to
agree with Tony on this one it's just a
building jack as for kisses kisses to
Mary Andrews for returning to Riverdale
and bonus kisses for her amazing Fred
supporting monologue and putting Archie
in his place you're amazing girl you
really are
kisses to Reggie's triumphant return to
Riverdale I'm glad to see you're okay
dude well that is until Ronnie sucked
you in the face I'll go ahead and throw
a kiss to that moment as well kisses to
the return of the vixens and the fact
that tawny joined the squad and kisses
to Betty for letting her hair down at
the slumber party it's so pretty girl oh
and fYI girl my inner circle vixens
kisses to Betty for sticking to her gut
and moving out of the Cooper house and
far away from chick and kisses to B for
standing by judgy during his oh so
dramatic protest and new political
aspirations and lastly kisses to Fred
for running against the largest for
mayor and to the potential of a
rekindled romance between Archie's
parents oh and kisses to all of you for
still watching this because this episode
was a long one and I'm a little winded
so I appreciate your sticking by my side
each and every week and there you have
it that does it for this weeks
after-show as always please give this
video a like and then hit the comments
with your hisses and kisses of the week
then tune in next week to the Sweetwater
secrets preview show for episode 217
chapter 30 the noose tightens to see if
your comment is featured Plus be sure to
follow me on Twitter because this
weekend I'm gonna be interviewing the
entire Riverdale cast about the rest of
season 2 and I want to pass along your
questions so tweet me what you want me
to ask the cast right now go thanks for
watching River babes and I'll see you on
Twitter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]